la plus grande opération de vaccination
jamais organisé en tunisie plus d'un
demi million de tunisiens ont reçu hier
une première dose dans les 3 135 centres
dédiés à cet effet plus de cinq cent
cinquante un mille doses administrées un
record pour cette journée nationale de
vaccination dans ce pays qui compte à
peine 12 millions d'habitants et dont le
taux de mortalité lié au corona virus
avait atteint des records ces dernières
semaines
plaçant la tunisie en tête des pays
sinistrés
lundi dernier c'était un appel du
président à de la république qui avait
demandé à organiser la plus grande
opération de vaccination
compte tenu de la disponibilité de plus
de 6 millions de doses reçues sous forme
de dons par des voisins et les
partenaires de la tunisie c'est des
milliers de médecins infirmiers et
personnel soignant bénévoles avaient
répondu présent et hier pour garantir la
réussite de cette mission je vous
propose est écouté aujourd'hui si nous
achevons la vaccination des plus de 40
ans nous commencerons la semaine
prochaine à vacciner les moins de 40 ans
d'ici au 15 septembre nous aurons vaincu
le virus ait enregistré un plus grand
nombre de vaccinations et nous aurons
ainsi surmonter et vaincu la maladie
j'ai entendu l'appel pour cette journée
d'ouverture le 8 août et je suis membre
de l'association in a rat nous avons
donc lancé un appel et rassembler un
certain nombre de jeunes hommes de
médecins de jeunes et d'étudiants
volontaires pour faire de cette journée
de vaccination une réussite et pour
fournir le plus de moyens possibles aux
tunisiens à notre peuple afin qu'ils se
fassent vacciner et qui puisse faire
face aux épreuves auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés une journée marathon de
vaccination qui s'est fait sous le
regard attentif du président de la
république qui s'est rendu dans l'un des
ses nombreux centres de vaccination à ce
rythme là la tunisie espère vacciner
l'ensemble de sa population dans les
mois à venir
à ce jour seulement 14 % de la
population ont reçu les deux doses de
vaccin